the truth about socialism that's a
subject of tonight's waters words there
was a big blowup on the view this week
Megan McCain and joy behar in a shout
fest over socialism think about a
percent and medicare social security
guards collection the post office
I hope Democrats do run a democratic
socialism because I think you lose
spectacularly and then I will look
forward to election night when I finally
get to tell everybody I told you so if
you end up running a radical I think you
should start paying the amount of taxes
that every socialist in this country
thinks you need to because if you think
the government is so good at spending
money look at the passions are running
high because a socialist rising star
knocked off Pelosi's protege and is
sucking up all the oxygen and the
democratic party Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez stumbled through weeks of gaffes
since her primary win and is being
forced to defend her socialist brand
this socialist label is something that I
think the media cares more about because
I don't knock on a person's door and is
like hey let me tell you about socialism
like that's yeah that's not how I
campaign if Fox News and if media want
to continue using this word then I use
the word I think by me saying oh no I'm
not this that in the other it just
becomes a distraction now let's look at
the facts about socialism shall we
Venezuela a rich country blessed with
bountiful natural resources is now a
hellhole look woods experiment with
socialism has wrought nearly 90 percent
now live in poverty starvation the
average person lost 24 pounds last year
and they're not trying to die it sick
people are taking dog medicine there's a
massive toilet paper shortage and it's
now the murder capital of the world
behind El Salvador if Democrats want to
bring socialism to America it makes me
wonder do they want to destroy America
now they're gonna say oh no we mean
Scandinavian countries that's where
socialism works
democratic socialism like Sweden the
Scandinavian socialism success story is
a liberal fantasy you know what
countries doing better than Sweden
Switzerland because it's a capitalist
powerhouse Sweden isn't even really a
truly socialist country anymore
Sweden was going off a cliff until about
a decade ago when conservatives took
over and implemented pro-capitalist
reforms plus these Scandinavian nations
are teeny and homogeneous
they don't even compare to America and
by the way did Scandinavia defeat the
Nazis put a man on the moon create the
iPhone no that was America what are the
major contributions to humankind from
Scandinavia IKEA this Cortes individual
says she wants free health care free
housing and free college free health
care alone costs 30 trillion dollars you
raise taxes on everyone in America and
that won't even make a dent in paying
that bill and if socialists don't trust
Trump why give the Trump administration
more power over your life you want Trump
in charge of your health care you want
Trump as your landlord you want Trump
running our colleges I thought you
didn't like Trump University the federal
government has a hard enough time taking
care of our vets securing the border and
protecting us from hackers the Obama
administration couldn't even launch a
website and you want to give the
government more responsibility so when
you hear people talk about socialism
just ask them where has socialism ever
worked